hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin kiss and
this is of course our year review
special he has been a brilliant year in
clown world and there's no one better to
discuss it than our two favorites sauris
and presenter Andrew doy and comedian
Jeff norcot welcome both back to the
show you're looking at each other
weirdly slightly uncomfortable that's
not weirdly that's sexual tension
because we only ever see each other over
Zoom don't we normally we do yeah on
podcasts and the like and I was thinking
this is actually cuz a lot of people
watch this and go oh here we go you know
not much diversity here but we don't do
diversity a trigonometry but having said
that I was going to point at you and go
Jew but that sounds bad but you are no
no it's apt for the current moment jewi
we've even got a little Palestinian
scarf if you want to wear it yeah the Y
and then homosexual homosexual and then
just gamon gam yeah yeah the way you
said homosexual was there a slight
element of judgment about it no no no I
judge myself for my inclination I would
just I I thought you'd just say gay but
homosexual say gay I think we should
reclaim
sodomite that's what I'm going with well
that's just not not just the gays I mean
anyway oh that's true that's true yeah
yeah you straight people steal
everything from us yeah well that is
kind of true and I like the way you said
homosexual as if to say there are two
Sexes and I'm attracted to the same sex
that's right yeah exactly cuz same sex
attracted has become a dog whistle yeah
apparently right when dog whistle we
we'll talk about all of that uh we've
got lots of stories from the year that
we've picked out to talk about believe
it or not the most upvoted story that we
had was actually about Nicholas sturgeon
which we'll come to in a minute yeah but
sort of working our way back
chronologically we could talk about Nial
and aaki and diversity that you brought
up or we could talk about October 7th
and the response which has obviously
been the biggest story in recent weeks
um so what did you guys make of that and
what I mean Andrew you've been warning
for ages about the left-going loopy yeah
uh sort of gone really loopy now well
that's that's the the thing about what
has happened since October the 7th is
that the there are elements of the left
that have exposed themselves really in
horrendous ways stuff like I I was
genuinely surprised by all of this stuff
that this kind of O overt expressions of
anti-Semitism on the Streets of London
people calling for Jihad and then other
people making excuses for them as though
a Jihad was just something something
sweet that you did something nice did
did you actually see the Met police when
hisb but teria which is a group who are
outl in most Arab countries calling for
Jihad in London the Met police put out a
tweet saying yeah but Jihad doesn't
necessarily mean holy war it can mean
lots of other things it can mean a kind
of face M Massage or yoga retreat or
something I don't know what they meant
but it was absolutely nuts that they
were doing that it's like no stop making
excuses for the very worst kind of
people and we saw it again and I know
there's always a few bad apples in any
protests but there seemed to be a lot of
rotten apples you know a lot of people
being very explicit what I thought was
interesting was the evolution of the
word sort of Zionist because if you get
like sort of far right loons they they
at least can they know that racist words
are bad words so if the camera's on them
they'll go and they'll they'll check
themselves and then they'll say a
different word potentially right but
then there is this sort of blind spot on
the other side which is where you go
Zionist I know what it used to mean I do
feel now that it just in a lot of cases
just means Jewish person you know and
then it's this kind of like workaround
that they've got where they could almost
get the far right in and have a seminar
and go look we've been doing some
incredible workout here and we've
realized uh we found another word you
can use and claim that it's not racist I
mean it has been an astonishing thing I
think there is like you know what's
happening over there is one thing but
like I know this country and I know that
what I've seen since October the 7th has
been startling yeah you know there's
just been this hierarchy hasn't there
that the the well if you want to call
them the woke they always had this idea
that there were different oppressed
groups and that they're on a a different
level of the hierarchy and Jews were
always privileged and so they can't
bring themselves even when there's a
massacre of over a thousand Jewish
people they can't bring themselves to
say this is anti Adit it this is a
pogram that whatever they they have to
whitewash it and work around I find that
an incredible blind spot well I mean
because the word the word was used in a
lot of cases was like minimizing you
know and it's like it's almost like from
the makers of microaggressions com
macroaggressions all macroaggression
there has been a subversion of a lot of
the things that we were told over the
last few years were uh were important
and I I I do think you know there is
that thing when you look at uh what's
happening a lot of people would sort of
say given what happened you know the
Israeli State you know had to do
something you can't let your civilians
feel like that on an ongoing basis
there's also the issue of the
concentration of population in Gaza and
whether or not the maximum care has been
taken to Pro protect civilians you know
that's definitely Up For Debate but it's
very hard as someone like me to know
enough about that to comment with with
total confidence but like I say when you
look at what's happened um repeatedly on
on the Streets of London you know I've
I've got Jewish friends who aren't like
you know they're not they're not prone
to like dramatism or anything like that
but they said that they don't want to go
in central London yeah anymore
particularly weekends and that that in
in you know 20123 is is bad Andrew and
the point about uh the Jeff makes about
you know who knows what's happening over
there with not I don't think any of the
four of us are Middle East peace process
experts exactly but the the reaction
domestically has been the thing that I
think has opened a lot of people's eyes
and we saw it recently with these uh
presidents or whatever they are of these
major American universities
being asked ining is calling for
genocide of the Jews harassment and
depends on the context which I actually
would sort of be fine with if that had
been consistent throughout the last
seven years whereas these people have
been like oh you asked me where I'm
from they I mean they've they've kicked
out students and professors for
microaggressions and less you know so
you know these are people who have been
rigidly policing speech on campus and
saying that they very very clear
violations of code of conduct and
actually it's based on the perception of
individuals so if people perceive that
they are offended or upset uh then
you're going to be punished for that but
calling for the genocide of Jews that
requires a bit more context bit more
discussion what is the argument it's
like as long as you don't do the
genocide that's they said they act it
out quite a hard thing to carry out so
you know you have to it's just you know
that in any other kind of historical
kind of grievance against the race of
people that those rules wouldn't have
been applied and again it's like from
the makers of words of violence comes
words words of just that's what I wish
that the whoever was doing the
questioning in Congress had said just
okay then in that case but from the
makers of words of no no not a Jeff
norcot routine like if she have just
said you know well is it okay to call
for the the mass murder of gay people
for instance is it okay to call for the
genocide of black people is that and to
put that question to them they would
immediately have to say no no no and
then you get to the Jews it's like
context so you know it's it's the double
standards I think that bothers everyone
you know I mean you could say you could
take an absolute Free Speech line and
say anything should be able to be said
on University campus but they should
apply it not just not just you know they
can't fall back on a free speech defense
when they've been so terrible at
upholding Free Speech standards in the
past it work why is it worse to say that
there are two biological Sexes and Men
Can't become women why is that worse
than calling for genocide of the Jews
because we're dealing with an ideology
that is internally inconsistent
incoherent so it doesn't you know you're
you're looking for rationality where
none can possibly exist but the the
thing that I I find bizarre is that
surely that is so obvious that anybody
would look at that and go yeah I mean
this doesn't make sense yeah you would
think the one thing I I wonder and you
know on this panel there is there is a
chance I'll be the woke one you
know you're in the comedy industry tell
us your PR are used are us saage are
used saage once lot of time but I do
think you know as as we're talking like
you know time recording you know the the
the death toll in Gaza mean whether or
not people take those numbers at face
value you know we're talking about
serious numbers even if it was half that
actually in a short space of time so I
am conscious of this thing of and some
people call it like mey mouthed of
trying to militate between all of these
things between concern for uh British
Jews between understanding why any
nation that experienced what happened on
October 7 would have to react but also
whether or not what's happening is
something that historically you know we
might look back at and go was was
maximum car taken is is it for us to say
I mean there was a report in the lanet
that that seemed to corroborate you know
the the health authority now is Hamas
health authority so it's really hard and
there's a lot of times where people have
said well if you give a nuanced answer
to this well you're an enemy or you're
complicit in one side or the other but I
mean this is a historical grievance it's
it's all about Nuance you know in a way
the one thing there's no new want about
is what happened on October the 7th and
and and that attack was so designed to
be disturbing right it it was it was it
was set up and predicated and designed
to disturb and appall and traumatize
people you know in in a way and what's
been odd since is people acting like
that wasn't in a way the intention of it
that's my view I mean my my concern
about that is I think you can have
nuanced discussions about you know is
the Israeli government doing enough to
prevent civilian death Etc you can have
a discussion about the history you can
talk about the establishment of of
Israel in the and whether you know there
were atrocities committed at that time
Etc all of those things you can have
that conversation without just being
completely blind to the sheer medieval
barbarism of what went on on October the
7th why can we not all agree that the
mass murder rape and torture of of
civilians is just horrendous and wrong
why that doesn't need that's my point
there's not a moral equivalent there's
really not a moral equivalent you know
you're dealing with a group of people
Hamas who are genocidal they are
explicitly they tell you they say they
want to wipe Jews from the planet they
want to wipe the state of Israel away uh
they film themselves murdering and
raping and torturing and put it out
there and boast about it and then we say
there's a moral equivalence between the
IDF who you know if they were trying to
commit genocide wouldn't be you know
showering the country with leaflets to
say get out so that you don't get killed
you know there is a there isn't a moral
equivalence between a terrorist group
that targets civilians for rape torture
and murder and a a military response to
that that actually goes out of it way to
avoid civilian death that is sure where
do we reach the point where those things
are comparable because I don't think
they are right and I also think it's
important I mean coming back to what
you're saying Jeff is to emphasize that
I don't think any of us has a
particularly strongly expressed position
on how Israel was created or the the
right military tactics because I don't
think any of us really are qualified to
talk about that effectively what I think
we're talking about is the reaction
domestically and I think it tells you a
lot about uh the state of our society
the people are making a that moral
equivalence I also think you know Jeff
will probably cringes the work one on
the panel but it tells you about the
impact of mass immigration on our
societies um from particularly from
countries where people are coming in
with values that just so alien to our
own um I wouldn't cringe it way I think
that what you have is like groups of
people that have priorities now and also
though they're like a cohort in the
electorate that actually there's a lot
of politicians that are getting elected
say we will represent you and then at
the point where there's an issue that
they all care about they're going all
right represent us and that where it
became tricky for the labor party
because they go oh you know it's nuanced
and they're say well not for us that's
why we voted for you we thought that you
would represent exactly what we thought
we thought you were the Muslim candidate
why AR you doing what Muslims want well
I I would believe more in a responsible
sort of form of politics where it's left
to that they're not a delegate it's not
like a union thing where you're tasked
you have to have one opinion on that
issue but I think that those these are
fault lines we've never crossed in
British politics before term there is
something very interesting in what you
raised as well in terms of our
commitment to Liberal values in this
country because a lot of people on the
anti-woke side are talking about are
advocating very sort of anti-liberal
perspectives now about deportations
about uh the idea that we just cannot
tolerate the intolerant and therefore we
have to uh impose these and I I I'm not
so you know ban protests for instance
arrest people for hate speech and I just
think if we're not you know steadfast in
our commitment say anyone should be able
to protest anyone should be able to say
whatever they want Even if we find it
apparent I think this has been a real
test all of this stuff has been a huge
test it comes back to the point about
the universities though Andrew because
if you have a situation where a bunch of
police officers are exchanging WhatsApp
messages and they get prosecuted for
that if someone goes and prays silently
outside an abortion clinic and they get
prosecuted for that if someone tweets a
trans transphobic inverted Comm as
limmerick and they get arrested for that
and then you have people openly calling
for Jihad on mass in the Streets of
London I don't think it's unreasonable
for people at that point to be like why
didn't we see some consist that's fair
yeah I think the public and the British
public generally got a fairly good sense
of fair play some of the interesting
stuff coming out of the protest was
being like people have said well there
was 300,000 people and so relatively
there wasn't much of this you go well 1%
of 3,000 is still a lot you know 300,000
is still 3,000 that's a lot of people
doing antiemetic stuff that's
interesting though because I've had
debate with a few people about do you
remember when there was that trans Pride
rally in London and a trans activist
stood up and said if you see a Turf
puncher in the [__] face and the
whole crowd cheered now for me that
suggests a normalization within that
movement of violence against women it's
not you know and it's incitement to
violence as well well there's that as
well so what I would say and people were
saying yeah but you can't tar everyone
with the same brush but I'm like if I
were at a protest and someone stood up
and called for violence and most of the
crowd cheered I would think I'm probably
in the wrong movement here I think
that's the point that antic signs right
why AR people grabbing them and saying
don't do that you're going to bring our
movement into why is it tolerated I
think you're right like there was a time
when that's you know people on the
Progressive left were saying well what
are you adjacent to that's what people
sometimes said to me about voting brexit
was like well who you know look who else
voted for that look who else was in
favor of that and then suddenly those
things are less important I mean there's
been like a very you know there's been
it's true that 300,000 people is a lot
of people 1% isn't a lot but like that's
so many different incidents and then the
police the police have done this weird
approach to policeing it whereby it's
almost like tag them in it's almost like
a classic modern social media thing do
you know who this guy is take him in
like no police in the moment please
because you cannot it's got justice has
got to be applied without fear or favor
so if you're saying well we don't want
to arrest that person there because
we're worried about what would happen
next you can't do that if in other
situations you would weigh in and it's
been yeah it has been an eye opener in a
way but like I wonder if like like like
brexit where our institutions were test
and actually whatever you think about
brexit they sort of did survive it in a
way is that these are sort of
conversations that we needed to have
obviously the reason we have them is is
is Dreadful but we're finding out a lot
more about what Britain is in 2023 and
there's also something as well which
people don't discuss because they don't
know enough about it so a little bit of
background my grandfather was from
Lebanon so he was an Arab and he was but
he was Christian but he Associated
Israel with Jews and he was vly
anti-semitic and wanted Israel to be got
rid of because it was partly because he
saw it as an Abomination what what
happened to the Palestinian people but a
large part of it was because he was
anti-semitic and the reality is that if
you actually ask a lot of people in that
crowd what their opinion is of Jewish
people and they were honest it's quite
unpleasant because look the history is a
history and it's complicated but there
is also a large dollop of racism and
hatred that is also mixed into this
issue which if people are honest and
they won't be it is impossible to
disentangle it it'd be good if they were
willing to apply because I think a lot
of people I I think a lot of those
people on those marches weren't
anti-semites but I think they're willing
to um sort of block out like they're
wearing blinkers if they if it's going
on to sort of deny that it's there and
and they also play they playing the word
games you know you have people openly
calling for inter father and you can say
yes well technically speaking that word
just means uh an uprising against
Injustice okay fine but then you have to
blind yourself to the the connotations
of that word you know we think of the
inter people in Israel think of the in
they think of mass murder of civilians
terrorist acts you can't just pretend
and wish away those connotations these
sort of word games I I just another
problem wasn't it where for a while we
were told that whatever people from a
community felt about a word or phrase
believe them you know hear their words
all all this stuff and then when you get
to the river of the sea it's going yeah
but they're a bit sensitive you know the
jewi you know again there's just there's
this complete there's this complete flip
I mean it I do Wonder as well with the
protest whether to a degree there's like
there is a lot of anger I think postco
I've never known in this country that a
lot of different people are angry about
a lot of different things so it's just
like this is the thing you go there on
Saturday this is the issue through and
I'm not saying people aren't emotionally
invested in this but for some people
it's just a way of expressing Express
like a broad anti-establishment
sentiment and some of it you know is
passionately felt but there there's also
been proper people's front of Judea
moments there was I mean I don't if you
saw the clip in McDonald's where
obviously people were told to get out
for McDonald's and there's this one lad
on the loud Haler and he was going like
everyone get out of the McDonald's and
there was a lot of people with
Palestinian Flags who were going no like
we getting we're getting chicken nuggets
and he you can see him sort of realize
that then no one's going to leave and
he's going and then he goes unless
you're going to use the toilets
suppose like his belief in the cause was
way for Finn and then his mate she said
the thing is the toilets in here don't
even work I thought how would you know
if you hadn't been here you know so
there there's been this thing where some
of it is is is vicious some of it is the
usual protest crowd and then some of it
like these people who are shouting and
people coming outside of McDonald's like
shame on you you can't they're sort of
laughing as they're doing it AR yeah
it's just [__] and Giggles for for some
don't you think it's also that thing of
there's a sense of it's compulsory so if
you have that mindset the woke mindset
you have to follow a certain set of
beliefs but like when it comes to the
Palestine Israel conflict they just know
automatically which side they're on even
if they know nothing about what's going
on I mean we've seen people interviewed
about River to the Sea what river what
sea are they talking about they don't
know or they're interviewing someone
about what happened on October the 7th
oh did something happen you know they
don't know it's it reminds me of the
brexit thing where where all my Lefty
friends who had no interest in the EU
never expressed an opinion on it in
their life suddenly started waving the
EU flag or painting their faces in EU
colors it's like you don't really care
about this you just know that in this
world that's the good side and you're on
the good side so therefore you have to
is that true of like on both sides of
whatever the culture War would be
supposed to be so if like if someone
says to you like they don't like Mega
marle you can kind of then go well you
probably don't like grer you probably do
like Top Gear you know like I think I
think you're right there's almost like
for some people and whatever the C
culture war is there's almost like this
kind of standard raft of opinions and I
think the most interesting people you
speak to in Britain in 2023 are actually
the people that will just surprise you
and go kind of like yeah you know I I'm
Pro one issue but actually you know like
like a proper gizer that oh I love bit
gr tumberg you go okay well you might be
worth speaking to because I didn't
expect you necessar important though
isn't it to be like I hate the fact that
I can so often predict someone's
opinions on everything if I know their
opinion on one thing just one thing and
that's not the case for some of my for
most of my friends actually I found that
people most people that I know now are
quite surprising do surpris me every now
and then in a position that they take
speaking you care on well I was just
going to say like with with Megan marle
there is no real reason that if you like
Megan marle you should be concerned
about the climate crisis there's no
logical reason that connects those but
it's this whole bunch of other stuff
that does somehow find itself part of it
we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to talk to you
about ag1 if you're a longtime fan you
might know we've been drinking ag1 for
over a year now to stay healthy and
Stave off illness in preparation for
whenever our schedule gets really busy
when we use ag1 on our busy America
tours we' found that we feel a real
difference to our energy levels and our
ability to focus so my concentration
span has gone from 2 seconds to 12
that's because ag1 is a foundational
nutrition supplement that supports your
body's Universal needs like gut
optimization Stress Management and
immune support since 2010 ag1 has led
the future of foundational nutrition
continuously refining their formula to
create a smarter better way to elevate
your Baseline Health even the
trigonometry team here have started
drinking ag1 and they love it our
producer was just telling me about how
much more energetic he feels that his
stress levels feel more manageable now
and because of this we're hoping he'll
hit his deadlines for the first time in
over 5 years ag1 is the supplement I
trust to support my daily health and
that's why they've been a trigonometry
partner for so long now if you want to
take ownership of your health it starts
with ag1 try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 and five free
ag1 travel packs with your first
purchase go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com
trigonometry check it out and now back
to the interview speaking of being
surprised I don't think any of us would
have had David Cameron being for forign
secretary no uh on our card of whatever
the card is for the year yeah no no just
just when you thought the Tories were
running out of ideas they brought that
old thing back I mean it's a it's a
weird one isn't it because because no I
didn't expect that at all but it's it's
it's it feels like a sign of desperation
like they don't really know what else to
do at this point well it's kind of weird
because James cleverly was sort of doing
a pretty decent job you know a lot of
people that worked with him said that
and then he gets thrown into like right
you got Rand
the legal bill you know the job of you
flying around meeting presidents no no
that's all done mate you've got
currently the hardest thing in the Tory
party and then I think Cameron comes
back it was genuinely the closest to
like an EastEnders Doof Doof moment I've
ever seen like we go it's David Cameron
he's not I'm back in the
square and he why do you think he did it
because I kind of think like he was in
hiding he was so embarrassed about
brexit and the pig thing the pig gate
thing which we've all forgotten by why
AR people making more of that you know
he's but he's come back you think he did
that though well the pig thing yeah oh
he definit I mean no no no no to be give
him his due yeah the accusation was that
he can I be explicit yes [__] a pig's
head yeah and and that's not true that
but you I would have thought so no what
he did was he placed his flaccid penis
into the dead Pig's mouth see I mean who
hasn't done that morally they are on
different levels but I'm not saying he
did by the way in case someone's going
to sue me that was the Alle that was the
allegation he placed his there was never
an allegation that he' had sex with a
dead pig but it became that he [__] a
dead pig yeah that that particular dead
pig but it clearly wasn't his type but
that does sound like a university like
initiation thing it sounds like
something that would have
happened I mean I I think at the time
that went that up in court by the way
just so you that sounds like something
that could have happened will not stand
up and will not okay well I I mean I'm I
I know he definitely didn't do it by the
way I mean Andrew was there I think also
there was an interesting moment like
when when he stepped out of that car
where you heard the journalist be
surprised and and this is just me
pushing my agenda here but K is it K
berley MH she was like oh he's put on
way and I thought M you would not say
that about like if a male news
journalist broadcaster Anor said that
about a female politician you go after
the break that guy won't be it right
like that's how quickly it it could
happen and and I thought you know it's
might it was it was you it wasn't the
most surprising thing about David
Cameron coming back either it's not
really great journalism and what was
really surprising when somebody comes
out of the Wilderness I guess it was the
only job that had the prestige that he
would have come back for foreign
secretary is the only one that's got a
big oh God yeah yeah and he also you
know they all want you know what is my
legacy and his has got worse and worse
ever since he left off don't they make a
lot of money though like ex- Prime
Ministers they do the tour they yeah but
it's not about money it's about ego yeah
it's definitely about ego at this point
what I thought was interesting as well
broadening it out a little bit is
obviously the reason that happened is
soel bravman made some pretty strong
worded comments about two-tier policing
about the protests about the marches Etc
she was removed uh she was basically
forced out because of that and that's
how we've ended up here and what seems
to me to be the long-term impact of that
is the Tory right which she represents
effectively is now going to Splinter off
certainly the voters to you know reform
or probably more likely not vote at all
we're going to have a general election
next year and I just wonder if if this
is isn't going to be an absolute
disaster for the conservatives I mean
absolute disaster it seems like to me
first thing to say s was correct about
the two that's absolutely right what do
the Tes think that they're doing who are
they trying should she like when you're
home secretary I I agree that most of
the public or or a good portion of the
public would see a lot of Truth in what
she said but when your Home Secretary
saying that about the police publicly
also in in an article you do have to
have a bit of collective responsibility
look I'll be honest I'm not the biggest
sella fan but I did feel at that point
she was sort of like a midfielder going
in putting in two footed tackles under
the nose of the ref going go and send me
off what El can you do because if you
think about it when pretty pel was Home
Secretary when so BR they give these
they issue these directives to the
police and the police ignore them
because they are so ideologically
captured or the same with the Civil
Service we had a whistleblower recently
talking about how in the Civil Service
any uh policy regarding immigration is
going to be ignored by the staff members
we just put it out an episode with Steve
Hilton former adviser to David Cameron
who basically told us story after Story
about how they tried to do things and
you just can't because the Civil Service
will sabotage anything you do that they
don't like exactly so if I were a home
secretary I'd be slagging off the Civil
Service constantly slagging off the
going for them publicly because they you
know in many ways I think people saw
soel bran as the one person who was
willing to slag off the people that
needed slagging off because nothing get
it's it's just about the the real
politique element of it like you know
like when Cameron said to um Jeremy
Corbin you know put on a tie and sing
the national anthem you know when you're
home secretary just one of the things
that you're going to run into trouble if
you do is if you slag off the police in
public I understand all the reasons that
you're saying where where the
frustration comes from but it becomes
very hard after that to to manage you
know manage relations and it puts it
puts you know it puts richy in this
weird I've sort of been calling him
Britney sunak a bit this year because
the amount of costume changes that the
Geyer has had in the space of of a year
you know he was stability guy you know
stability rishy Den he was what was it
long-term decisions for a better future
guy then he was ues richy he was like
[__] the climate you know then he was
like and then then and then now he's
then he was the change guy yeah at um at
conference I the change candidate and
now he's actually let's just bring back
David Cameron and it looks like it looks
like bring your dad to workday I mean
the thing is if you're already the Prime
Minister looks most like an 8-year-old
boy right I would not have someone who
looks like your dad and your uncle
coming along with you I mean he I think
he's found himself because the polls
haven't changed in a year he's just
found himself lurching and and the
impression that the public get and I
think it's a fair one is that he doesn't
really have a a core set of principles
at at this point no but you could say
that about starma as well I think that
they are two cheeks of the same ass like
yeah the problem is though is going back
to the sella thing is that what it
really means is that
democracy doesn't exist because people
voted for the conservatives because they
wanted a government that is conservative
that had conservative policies but if a
conservative government can no longer
Implement conservative policies because
the blob or whatever the Civil Service
whatever you want to call them refuse to
enact them then what are you left with
so what's going to happen next time then
you know because labor will get in and
then the conservative party presumably
will shift to the right because that's
what the voting base want and then
you'll get a full-on hardcore Tory
government that does a bonfire of the
quangos but but they Civil Service B
fire the quangos does sound like those
weird one of those weird films from the
70s
Paulman go yeah did purely for the money
but but I I disagree that I don't think
they do it no I because I don't think
they can do it or there's certainly not
the political will to be able to do it
because if you're going to do it you're
going to get into this new though like I
mean we used to have a program called
like Yes Minister Yes Prime Minister
it's but this idea of the Civil Service
pushing back for continuity maybe it's
just something that occurs when either
Administration flips to the right or
indeed the left right whether but you're
whether that's Democratic or not is is
another issue entirely problem is with
the way the Press operate in this
country is that if you talk about like
civil service or even if you criticize
Public Health bodies it's all trumpian
you know or it's trumpan when when when
you this like I mean this Co inquir has
proved it that there are civil servants
with quite clear agendas you know that
are take effectively take political
decisions it's fine now if we have that
conversation with the British public and
the British public go on fine with that
fine but we've never had that chat
really and Jeff none of the three of us
has really followed the the co inquiry
what I hear out of it is exactly the
opposite of what I wanted to hear out of
it it seems we didn't lock down fast or
hard enough apparently that's their
conclusion is that right well I the
thing was I thought is it to inquire
what happened or is it to prosecute the
idea that the government were [__] show
right and it's certainly with people
like Hugo Keith KC that seems to be his
focus and you know there's all these
salacious whatsapps and oh he called
himself a tit [__] or a or a bum wankle
you know and and and that has been you
know that has been what's often led the
news whereas I think genuinely the
interesting thing that comes out of it
is how did the instruments of State work
Under Pressure we know what happened
with the government most people have
come to their conclusions but the Civil
Service don't come out of it well and
also a lot of decisions that people
fought with the governments were
actually Sage but because again there's
this thing in the liberal press whereby
oh you know somehow Health bodies and
the Civil Service are sacran to never
make [__] decisions they never make
egotistical decisions like for example
like the chelam festival a lot of people
were frustrated that that went ahead
that was under Sage advice you know
literally under Sage advice so I I
actually think that the the headlines
that have come out of the inquiry have
been pitiful really oh Boris probably
shouldn't have shaken someone's uh
patient's hand at the hospital going we
all kind of had that chat around the
same time all those celebrities were
singing imagine you know and then three
years later this is headline news I
think the much more interesting thing is
who you know who do we rely on for our
health advice and Did they perform under
pressure
and don't you think that this is all too
little too late and what it's pointless
isn't it it's pointless well I don't
think it's going to change U many
people's minds but you know with with
sunak testimony what was interesting was
you finally get this discussion of
whether or not you know risk versus
reward and I'm sure those questions have
been asked but they certainly not been
the ones that have been leading uh the
the news at 10 and the general sort of
spirit of it is it should have gone
sooner harder long all these porny
pornographic Ty sooner
but actually you know if you look at
Omicron it was the opposite so they say
if you're going to make a decision make
it soon make it hard make it long and um
whereas Omron if we'd have done that
we'd have screwed the economy even
harder for for a lot longer when
actually we found that that was the
right decision was to wait for more
evidence so as you watch the inquiry do
you come away from it going if there's
another pandemic in my lifetime yeah
we're going to smash that one
we well I think it'll be more like that
show you've seen the last of us you know
where just everyone yeah yeah kind of
zombie I think it would be more like
that it just it' just be get get a
machine gun ah head for the hills yeah
it just seems like we haven't actually
learned any of the actual lessons I mean
when you look at Sweden for example and
and what they were able to do there the
comparison is night and day to me and
instead of looking at them and going how
could we adjust what we did to get
better results we like you said it's
about Prosecuting the politicians who
who we want to hold guilty you won't get
compliance will you if it happens again
as in people now know that the masks are
ineffective so no one's going to wear
mask you say that Andrew I thought you
wouldn't get comp I never thought the
British public would accept this curtain
twitching [__] looking oh he's gone
out for a second walk [__] but we
all did well there's still a majority
there's still uh 20% of people think the
nightclub should be shut forever they're
still
10 they called your
audience there's still 10 10% of people
that think that we should have a 10 p.m.
curfew you know so the these people I I
think that they would I think you're
right but I think that there will be
less compliance and and this thing about
Prosecuting an idea I mean there's been
so much ego from some of the KC's and
he's got this little code Hugo keeth
where he sort of says um forgive me
which means I think that's bollocks but
or he says is it not the case he go oh
you're going to tell us what you think
now mate is it not the case that um that
was a [__] show you know you think I I
didn't think and maybe this is how they
work inquiries maybe it's the first one
I've watched closely but I didn't think
it was supposed to be like you've got a
Theory of Everything went wrong and then
you essentially cross-examine I thought
you you just ask questions maybe find
out what happened but I guess maybe you
have to put them under pressure to get
the truth I think that the problem is
with with covid is that it turned us
into like we all thought it was like you
know when you watch England football
team you go yeah I could do better than
that you know but everybody thinks that
they could have looking back thinks that
they could have handled it better well
at the same time and look the the
government made huge mistakes and I
disagree with a lot of what they did but
I also think we forget how terrifying it
was to cons mind back to early March I
mean I don't know about you but you know
I was bricking it well I mean one of the
things that were a lot more of a way
back then it's true mate one of the
things that that come out was like how
quickly things happen so the idea that's
taken roote in the public psyche is that
the the government like delayed for a
long long time before locking down the
first mention of lockdown was in early
March something like 7th of March in
cabinet and lock down happened on the
13th of March so it's true that those
delays might have caused you know like
more deaths and stuff but in terms of
amount of days the perception is now
that they were just sitting on their
asses Boris Boris The Trolley you know I
mean there's been some funny stuff
that's come out of this let's be honest
the calling calling I I'll definitely
use the idea that a mateer changes his
mind a lot is the trolley I mean that's
that's a good that's a good nickname all
the fact that a prime minister got
brought down for having a cake well in
in the end it was it was the the the
Chris pincher guy wasn't it again oh it
was pincher yeah this is how we remember
stuff we remember the cake I mean let's
be honest that weakened him
significantly but yeah i' sort of
forgotten about P the cake is much more
guys is this not pathetic this
conversation is so pathetic we're
talking about prime minister being
brought down by K con it was a handsy
bloke called pincher let's never forget
that that happened in British public
life I mean yeah in a way it dovet tales
with the inquiry in a way is that they
tended that the coverage of the
inquiries tended to lead on the most
frivolous stuff and I think that's a
real disservice that's what I mean but
anyway uh speaking of British politics I
mentioned earlier the most upvoted story
from our supporters for us to talk about
was one Nicholas sturgeon we actually
have a clip of her talking about this
issue we'll play that and we'll chat
about it let's get that up trans women
are are women but in the present context
there is no automatic right for a trans
woman there are contexts where a
transwoman is not a woman no there
is there is circumstances in which a
transwoman will be housed in the male
prison estate because any context in
which a woman born as a woman will be
housed in the male estate look we're
talking here about trans women and I'm
now asking about women born as women I
don't think there are circumstances
there H but so it's different for trans
women well yes and I'm not so they're
not equal that is not the there is a
risk assessment process done for trans
women that takes account of the nature
of the crime it clearly
significant concern arises out of sexual
crime and whether it's appropriate for
them to be in a female prison or a male
prison moving on to your legislation
should someone who has a history of
committing sexual crimes against women
be allowed to get a gender recognition
certificate well there are of course
Provisions in that legislation which is
not yet in Force whereby if somebody is
going through the process of getting a
gender recognition certificate and there
are concerns um about that that there
can be a
pause
OT and do we not also have some articles
about what's happened with her later so
she's resigned obviously
and slow down so her husband was then
arrested and her their house was surged
um and they uh and also the other thing
that's happened lately is is the UK
government banned uh not banned uh the
UK government prevented their act from
going through and it's been found that
that is legal the fact that they've
prevented it from going through right so
I think the reason people wanted us to
talk about it is a we have a lot of
turfs that watch this right number one
they love it they absolutely love a bit
of love trans birds love transmit it's
it's a catchphrase of the show Jeff is
cringing because he's the woke one for
this for the purpose yeah CU I say that
I was very problematic what saying Birds
well I also think that with with the
people that watch your show is given how
the Year's been politically the downfall
of Nicholas sturgeon was like the one
bright spark for people that's the thing
that kept me going through the difficult
months well the reason I think people
care about is obviously we just saw it
exposes the complete you know moral
inconsistency of everything that they're
saying it doesn't make sense they're
trapped in in the faulty logic of their
own argument but also there was then the
possibility that she might be arrested
and prosecuted and go to prison and
that's where it really gets interesting
because I think a lot of people feel
like the reason these crazy ideas uh are
able to mature to the point where
they're represented at that political
level is it's luxury beliefs Rob
Henderson who we've had on the show
talks about this which is it's people
having ideas whose consequences they're
never affected by yeah and suddenly this
woman who's pretending that is it Isa BR
Isa Bryson Isa grah two-time rapist
absolutely male being sent to a female
prison is okay this person might be
about to go to prison themselves and how
that's why she was in such a muddle I
mean but the thing is like she talks
about a risk assessment for Isa Bryson
whose real name is Adam Graham double
rapist they were housing him in the
female estate while they made that
decision what risk assessment do you
need double rapist that answers your
question doesn't it then then and that
was the thing about you know when
Westminster vetoed the the agender
Reform Bill and which they were right to
do so we forget that there were all
these amendments tabled to that bill the
S&P could have made this palatable right
there were amendments to protect Single
Sex spaces in in hospital Wards uh there
single sex baces in prisons uh they they
were saying that that prisoners uh who
had been who were on trial for rape
couldn't suddenly apply for a GRC during
the process all like sensible stuff and
they just they just said no so in other
words the bill was faulty and wrong they
knew it would be veto they were warned
it would be vetoed and they did it
anyway humza youf took this took you
know took Westminster on knowing he
would lose I mean everyone said you're
going to lose this has been an absolute
shambles uh from start to finish and so
she deserved to get to get nailed on
this and by the way we're not talking
about the the dodgy coruption and and
the accusations because there they have
very strict contempt of court rules in
Scotland so nobody's really been talking
about it but it dwarfs Boris Johnson and
the cake like this this is a like but we
we should be talking about this a whole
lot more but we probably can't this idea
that you can sort of like you're saying
I mean the fact that we for a moment a
politician in Britain was considering
this idea that you can have this prison
onset gender dysphoria like you get to
the courtroom and suddenly oh I'm a bit
TR like it's ridiculous no but they are
now I mean the Scottish government is
now saying what they will do is that
they will still house men in the women
estate if they identify as women uh that
they're saying they're doubling down on
this but they're saying you know that
they they're reducing the numbers but
they say We'll organize sort of day out
so that the the trans identifying people
can go and associate with women in the
women's prison they are seriously
considering this and I would have
thought that you look it works doesn't
it just segregate prisons by sex it
works it's it's per you know it's
perfectly fine and why are they so
obsessed with the feelings of rapists
why are they worried about them why
aren't they worried about the women in
prison who are among the most vulnerable
women in the country surely they they
should be the priority right I would
have thought I think what what was
fascinating about it was that when the
UK government in Westminster government
intervened there was a majority support
for that among S&P voters now I would
say if you're a nationalist party and
and your voters are supporting the
intervention that you couldn't have got
it more wrong and there's been this
Paradox in the snp's politics for for a
while both like you know on one hand
want to be out of the Union that is
Britain and the UK uh but want to be
part of the EU you know and there is
also this sort of line between their
politics which is Independence I don't
want Scotland to leave the UK but I
understand that sentiment and this
Progressive agenda that's actually not
necessarily you know nationalism in
Scotland used to be coming from a more
conservative place you're right that the
voters they overwhelmingly didn't
support because we keep hearing this
this this Bill had cross-party support
75% of of of Scottish uh
parliamentarians supported it but the
public really didn't so is it the case
at the S&P because they've always relied
on this thing that you know it's all
about independence and the the support
has been because there's this passion
this nationalistic fervor in the country
that they could just endorse any
ridiculous policy and bring these people
along like they're trolling them do you
know it's like it's like you know Sky
Sports like Sky Sports a lot of people
get it because you go want the football
yeah football is independence and then
they go Sky Sports you get the badminton
as well you go I'm not really interested
in the badmon I want the football the
football is I think they're pushing it I
think they're taking the piss like what
else can we introduce why don't we
introduce a hate speech bill that makes
it illegal to say things in your own
home let's do that everyone will hate it
doesn't matter because they one
Independence In fairness I should I
think if I'm not mistaken it was part of
their Manifesto in 2019 so they have
sort of sought but again it doesn't
matter but but whether or not how high
that was up the average S&P voters um uh
priority list we can only we can only
speculate and I do think that there is a
sort of symmetry between the S&P and the
stories in a way is that if you're in
power long enough there's like a hubris
that Creeps in and there are blind spots
there are things that you do because
you've been in power so long you forget
that you have to refer to the people I
mean like you know example where the
Tories started going wrong I know we'll
get back to S&P but was actually the own
Patterson thing was where one of their
mates got found guilty of something in
by the Privileges committee and well
we'll change the rules and people well
that well that's the worst stereotype
about you is that there's different
rules for people than there is for you
and the S&P have had a succession of
things now that have almost run in
tandem with the Tories in Westminster
and it's almost like this subconscious
thing of maybe you don't want to be in
power anymore isn't it good that they're
being punished for it though I mean like
even if you take just on the terms of
the cause or the campaign for Scottish
independence the support now is much
much lower like they were edging towards
that majority they needed that if they
did have a referendum they would win
they held it now they'd lose and that is
because of all these other batshit
policies that they've they've advocated
for they've lost support for the
independence as well ultimately that's
that's what's happened but it's you know
they say that about TV series the term
jump the shark is when they do something
in the series it becomes so ridiculous
and it becomes so unbelievable that
everybody goes like you know what I'm
done and I can't watch this anymore and
the is of Bryson case for me was the
moment the S SMP jumped the metaphorical
shark if you remember back during
question time where I it was an S SMP me
there was an S SMP member of Scottish
Parliament and they asked her is IA
Bryson a man or a woman and she went
they're a rapist and no no that's not
what I'm asking I think it was actually
uh I think who was it it was I can't
remember but then she was asked again
yeah are they a man or a woman they they
were a rapist and all you heard from The
Question Time audience was this huge
audible groan yeah and I was looking at
that and listening going you're done
it's over well I mean in that interview
that we saw with sturgeon there's that
point where the Paradox of her thinking
almost Dawns at her and she l she
realizes she's hit a point now like if
she was essentially consistent in her
thinking she should have just doubled
out and said no that you know that is B
said is a woman and therefore Brave and
beautiful woman and and that absolutely
should be housed in a female prison but
what she once you've acknowledged that
there are some exceptions well now now
we're just it's like that old Oscar wild
card now we're just discussing the
details we've established what you think
now we're just discussing uh the final
details isn't it scary to think though
that it was a kind of coincidence that
brought her down in so far as that Isa
Bryson case happened to happen at the
time that they were pushing through the
bill and it's that visual image you know
of that guy in that dodgy wig with his
leggings that showed his male genitalia
you know that image everyone's like what
they were going to put him in a in a
women's prison that's what changed it
it's like there are these moments there
are these visual things that happen and
if it weren't for that I think they
would have got got away with it we'll be
back with our guests in a minute but
first do you remember the Canadian
trucker protest in 2022 where thousands
of Canadians came out to protest Co
restrictions and vaccine mandates now
these protests lasted for weeks and the
people out on the streets needed funds
as any Grassroots protest would so
people set up online crowdfunding
campaigns which rais millions of dollars
incredible but once the Canadian
authorities had started to criticize the
crowdfunding platforms ramping up
pressure to close the campaigns it
didn't take long for the biggest
crowdfunding platform the one we've all
heard of to completely capitulate and
shut the campaigns down now this is
where our partners give send go come in
they stepped in when the other platforms
backed off and raised millions of
dollars for the truckers when they were
criticized and dragged through the
Canadian courts GFS and go said it
respected diverse views and believed
hope and freedom are values worth
fighting for this is why we're proud to
partner with gifs and go so if you need
to crowdfund for whatever means the most
to you then don't go to the Big 10
platforms we recommend you do it on gend
go starting a campaign on give send go
is easy and intuitive go to giv send
go.com today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever is important
to you and now back to the interview and
Andrew you were just saying there's an
article about a recent case you
mentioned that essentially quite
consistently now in the UK media when
there's a case about a trans woman a
biological male who's committed some
kind of horrific offense it's always
covered in a way where you don't get
told that they're trans until the very
end of the article so that people don't
have their bigoted thoughts about that
and now they don't even do that right
what what was this article so the the
recent article about Naomi O'Brien ell
can you pull that up as well so naom
Naomi O'Brien was complicit in uh the
abuse of a four-year-old child um Naomi
O'Brien is a man the article on the BBC
about this actually had the phrase
predatory woman in the headline uh the
the the one of the police officers a
spokesperson for the police for the
greater Manchester police used the
phrase predatory female predatory woman
everyone's lying about this the police
know that this is a man the media know
that this is a man the BBC know that
this is a man now the BBC used to slip
in at the end of an article they they
they'd use she her pronouns for a male
uh rapist you're not just not talking
about the headline here you're talking
about the whole article not not once in
this BBC article does it mention that
this is a man so it's it's she her all
the way through there is no not even
like this is someone who identifies it
not even transgender that word isn't
even used it's just a woman whereas if
you take there was an article last year
which was about a New York serial killer
who uh dismembered women um and you know
and you read that and it was all about a
woman you thought this doesn't sound
like a woman and then in the last in the
penultimate paragraph it said who
recently identifies as a woman you're
like oh yeah it's a bloke of course it's
a bloke yeah um so they used to do that
and now the BBC has moved into just out
flat out saying this is female this is a
woman with no and people are getting
sick of it because for for two reasons I
think firstly it's not true so so it's
journalistically it's really deeply
unprofessional and unethical but also
because they don't have to do this we've
been under this delusion that all these
media Outlets that use she her pronouns
for for for rapists are obliged to do so
because of IPO say or because of ofcom
and none of that is true there is no
reason why they do this it doesn't have
to be even right-wing newspapers do it
right why what what so what do you think
then and I'm mildly Playing devil's
advocate in that headline what what
would you prefer to see what do you
think that in give you know from the
BBC's point of view of getting some
balance between things how should they
how should that headline run transgender
Predator incited man to abuse child
would have done it MH or man so I I'm
also very uncomfortable with the with
the phas I believe balance is important
but in this instance we we ought not to
have balance between truth and lies it
is objectively not true that this person
is a woman right so I don't want the BBC
to present me a balanced position on
whether gravity is real or I mean is
just just the the situation that they
because obviously if they were to go
down that road and there's a lot of
really strong arguments why why they
could and indeed should is that they're
then going to get kicked back the other
side that's what I'm wondering is like
what is what yeah that that crime stats
are being skewed if I was a woman don't
get me wrong if if I was a woman i'
would be
I mean what an incredible phrase for me
to use woman Jes Christ I am as as I
look all you need to say is I am a woman
if I was woman if I was I'm the wild I'm
this if I was like one of the things if
you look at the relative merits of the
biological Sexes right is that you say
your men have qualities women have
qualities one thing that we could
generally say is that we're not broadly
speaking the violent ones we're not the
ones that do [__] depraved [__] all
the time so looking at from a woman's
point of VI you to have that down on
your chart and your score you can
absolutely understand the rage yeah and
they are and they are this does result
in Mis we don't know how many of these
rapists are male or female because the
so many police forces are recording
crime by gender identity not by
biological sex I mean there was a
freedom of information request by a
group called keep uh prison Single Sex
and I think 24 odd police forces
responded and I think 15 of them said
they report they recorded crime by
gender identity two said that they did
it by biological SE
uh which means that even the police
don't know right and again there is no
legal requirement for the police to
record gender identity instead of
biological sex it's not there so all of
these people are independently making
these decisions that skew the crime
stats and that's really really bad for
everyone because it's the the truth
matters right the truth I mean one of
the things I've been conscious of over
the last few years is that we've lost
distinctions between now your trans can
mean anything from somebody that's fully
you know transitioned their body as far
as they can and been living you as a
woman for so many years and somebody
that's made a very short-term decision
and that's where I I do worry for people
that were living essentially calm and
Serene lives that had gone through that
and broadly speaking I think if you go
through that that is genuinely how you
feel if you literally change your body
now I understand some people would never
see that person as fully a biological
woman and and maybe the problem is we've
lost this
distinction just saying trans actually
covers such a broad range of experience
within that it's really but we didn't do
that
activist St said that there's now a
trans umbrella which includes trans what
you're talking about is transexuals
which is what most of us thought of as
trans all those years ago people have
gone through the procedure who won Big
Brother now that wasn't yeah Nadia so
everyone's like that a transwoman and
and it really wasn't an issue and then
when you got people that were wanting to
make very short-term decisions with very
little commitment in their private life
to that difference suddenly those got
merged into one thing and I think that's
again one of those moments where the
British public who essentially I think
broadly if someone has fully
transitioned their body would certainly
relate to that person as a woman if
that's what they chose suddenly felt
well there's a massive [__]
difference between those two things but
that's the problem so so a lot of people
are very deeply supportive of the kind
of person you describe who needs to go
through that terribly expensive and
painful surgery to be uh to to feel
comfortable in their life most people
have sympathy for those individuals and
they would consider them you know we
want you to you'd want to support them
but when you bring in that um same
umbrella fetishists crossdressers you
know someone who just throws a wig on
and does no nothing else like the Green
Party candidate Melissa pton now that
image of of of him just just saying yeah
anyone who criticized me as a trans
phobe you just think it's he's not even
a good wig you know I mean so so like
you're you're bringing in all these sort
of people does it come down to wig I I
think it comes down to wig quity then
that becomes a class
issue could afford better wigs but it's
not a transexual yeah yeah that's aoke
who's put a wig on that's not the same
as a transexual right but we've lost
those those and that's been so I've you
know through trying to talk about this
on my podcast I've had people who have
got in contact with me saying that you
know there is a legal requirement of
time to where you do have to sort of as
you're transitioning essentially just
present as as a woman so is there a
point in that process is it that when
You' fully changed your body what is
what is the point at which someone can
legitimately at least sort of represent
for you as that gender then and I realiz
I'm getting very concep that's a good
point and and it is a problem like a
benchmark moment because you're saying
what I think what you're saying is
somebody putting on you know on a wig
like there's that that very early part
which a lot of the public would have
hesitations about but where is it along
that it's not no because you're talking
about early within a process where
someone is is is it's tending towards
transexualism surgery the vast majority
of the people who we now call Trans have
no intention of uh removing their
genitalia or male genit or anything of
that kind they just want to be treated
as women have access to women's spaces
even though they are intact male bodies
and that's something that is very very
dangerous so and it's that conflation
that I think has caused all the problems
and it's also why so many decent people
have gone on board with really
reactionary ideas because they think
they're supporting transsexuals but
they're not that's what I think has
happened here and it goes back to your
original point when we were talking
about anti semitism which is the power
of ideology where you have a mantra
which is trans women or women well what
does that mean it means that anyone can
be a woman anyone can identify as a
woman which means you obliterate the
meaning of the term right so if you if
you take this year we had Jenny Watson
who had a speed dating lesbian event uh
there was a guy who identified as female
who turned up was very handsy with some
of the lesbians in the toilet uh and it
got to the point where Jenny Watson had
to say look we this is just for
biological women for
lesbians uh and then the the event got
shut down because activists went after
the venue right so if you have a
situation where lesbians cannot Gather
in a romantic context speed dating
without men demanding entry that's
that's to me that's really regressive
and that's what's happening but it comes
down to again the fair play limit I
think most people recognize that to be
an an unreasonable development you know
like that is a a freedom of Association
more but but but if you say trans women
and women have to be treated as women in
law then actually it's right to shut
that down
Andrew can I ask you something that may
sound a little personal but you are
someone who has covered this issue a
hell of a lot and I know that in private
conversations we've talked about that
this is something that is particularly
affecting gay children yeah and I know
that for a lot of lesbians and gay men
in particular it's a it's a kind of
personal issue as well because they sort
of look at it and go you know what if
this had been happening when I was a boy
or when I was a girl I might be one of
these people I might have been LED down
this path that's why so many gay
activists are coming out of retirement
to deal with this issue and that's why
the notion of an lgbtqia plus Community
is such a lie uh because so many of the
of the principles behind the TQ plus
aspect of that are directly antithetical
to gay rights that's the problem so now
we live in a time where it's the most
dangerous time to be a gay kid basically
because when I was at school it you know
you for a start you wouldn't be out
there were no there's no such thing as
an out gay kid at school at the time I
was at school you would be beaten up
you'd be bullied you'd be have
homophobic be from the staff from the
teachers but now if you're a gay kid uh
you'll have uh figures of authority
teachers Stonewall mermaids implying
that you might be in the wrong body and
you need to be put on a pathway to
medicalization now no one saw that
coming no one saw coming the idea that
that uh we'd be medicalizing gay kids in
the name of progress that's such a
bizarre sort of situation and because
between 80 and 90% of adolescent
referred to the tavestock clinic were
same sex attracted we know that this
overwhelming is about fixing gay kids
heterosexualized un unlikely that might
be the net effect of it well why then
did so many whistleblowers at the T
stock say there was homophobia endemic
in a lot of the referrals why did they
have a dark joke why did they have the
joke soon there'll be no gay kids left
why did they have that well I'm just
it's very hard for someone like me you
know I'm looking into various different
communities I don't you know fully
understand but how a sort of left wi
Progressive organization I do think have
got got it wrong on so many things but
would become homophobic how did that
happen yeah I really want to know the
answer to that question
exactly it did happen but I think what
what you know groups like Stonewall and
mermaids as far as I'm concerned
represent the biggest threat to gay
rights at the moment they are anti they
are hostile to gay rights but they don't
say they are or agree and I don't even
think they think they are I think you're
right I think they this that they have
actually bought into this ideology to
such a degree that they are advocating
and promoting anti-gay ideas in the name
of being PR gay I think they are I think
you're right I think it is a a complete
you know and I and I and I feel that
that's why a lot of gay people are
frustrated when they see that progress
progress pride flag spattered every a
load of G people think that that
basically if that's outside a pub they
feel they won't go in because they might
get attacked verbally abused whatever
and it used to be the case that the
rainbow flag was like well I know I can
go in there and I can hold my
boyfriend's hand and I won't get trouble
for it if I see the progress pride flag
now I do not go into that bar what I'm
worried someone might start verbally
abusing me right well but just for being
G for having a view on same seex
biological attract being samex attracted
is in is a counter to this ideology in
and of itself because it implies that
there's only two Sexes well they say
being same sex attracted is a dog
whistle right so what they so so
Stonewall on its website and its
promotional materials changed the
definition of homosexual to mean same
gender attracted right activists say
things like genital preferences are
transphobic not all activists but some
do um they have this idea that you
that's why grinder now is full of young
women who who've been led to believe
that they're men uh that's why uh in
Australia it's illegal for lesbians to
gather now because you have to admit men
so but gay people aren't attracted to
the way that you perceive yourself like
gay men aren't attracted to people who
think they're men they're attracted to
men and lesbians aren't attracted to
people with penises because they're
lesbians this is the thing there this
thing called homosexuality this is blow
my mind it's an education and the title
of this episode would be the red filling
of Jeff just just so much to to think
like that homosexuality gay rights has
been secured on the understanding that
there are people who are innately
attracted to members of their own sex
but now those people are being shamed
for it wait you don't include people
with penises in your dating pool lesbian
then you are evil bigger so this is the
question maybe I'm asking is I think
that that view that you're expressing
absolutely exists it's how prevalent
right if we get outside of social media
or or even more Metropolitan type
centers if you go to an old gay Pub in
wolver Hampton you know are we we saying
you know what there AB there absolutely
is I did a gig there in 2005 and it it
was it was terrible I'm not sure I was
the right
booking is what I would say that's what
I'm wondering I'm wondering if like
maybe those voices that you're talking
about
disproportionate volume within the
debate but I wonder how broad that but
not just the debate they also have a
disproportionate impact on government
policy police Behavior they're in the
College of policing they're in an NHS
giving trainings Etc that's the issue
it's not about you know Andrew spent too
much time on social media it's about the
fact that this is having an impact on
real people yeah that's I mean it
wouldn't matter so much if it wasn't
impacting people all these kids who've
gone through now uh you know puberty
blockers which almost always lead to
cross- sex hormones and sometimes
surgery that cannot be undone I've met D
transitioners I met a gay guy who's just
an effeminate gay guy and he doesn't
have genitals anymore because he was
encouraged to go down this path and it
does sort of matter I think well it
matters Jeff's looking at his watch so
when we no I wasn't looking at watch I
was just about to make a really flippant
joke and then you said something very
serious and I just looked down CU I
thought I am so glad I didn't make that
joke said can I can I make the point
though about look in Iran the government
funds sex changes because they hate they
hand gay people from cranes or they just
really Progressive Ang well you say that
but when P when the Pakistan government
started doing a similar thing which
they've since stopped doing yeah pink
news put out a video saying oh great
Pakistan has said yes to trans rights no
the Pakistan government was funding SE
changes because they they kill gay
people I am genuinely blown away by this
see this is why you stay away from this
issue cuz if you listen to enough people
talk about it you eventually come out
very hard line on it no I mean look I
get I'm getting what you say but it's
when pink news were hyping the Pakistan
government well okay okay so speaking of
progress as we wrap up this particular
uh segment of the conversation Andrew do
you feel that with some of the things we
have seen this year in this country we
actually have made progress in terms of
the push back against this we saw the
Tabo Clinic the cast report we we've
seen all sorts of other things happening
where you go okay some of the madness is
being dialed back a little bit I that's
absolutely right I think it's because of
what Jeff was saying is that most people
don't know it's going on right just most
people just don't realize they thought
that the tavat was just helping kids who
were suffering from gender dysphoria
they didn't realize that it was you know
what 35% of referrals were autistic as
compared to 2% of the population they
had all sorts of other co-morbidity co-
isues going on that all of this is
coming out now kmy badok has mentioned
this in Parliament has talked about
transing away the gay has talked about
people who are using the the the
ideology of gender identity and
effectively
heterosexualized of the game mens
Network and he was saying like the stuff
that kmy badut was saying in Parliament
would have got a banned from social
media a few years ago but now it's out
in the open Stonewall always had this
idea of no debate that was their
official policy we don't debate this you
know because their ideas were so ex one
of their guys on the new literally
saying I can't talk about this because
it's so obvious it's a settled issue not
so that that so what's happened is you
have a minority of activists with
incredible power in society who are
treating their own extremist views and
presenting them as though we've reached
an established consensus in society and
it's not true and now what's happening
is people are waking up to it more and
more people are seeing the impact of
gender identity ideology in in schools
and it on on their kids and and to gay
people and to women especially and and
they're pushing back against it so I
think it's I think it's all it's going
to end I think I mean honestly I'm
feeling very optimistic I think too many
people know about it now you know it's
going to take a long time to unpick it
like the Welsh government is basically
putting out gender identity propaganda
in all of their uh teaching materials
and stuff like that they're going to
they're probably doing something that's
not actually legal because the uh Ed the
um Education Act actually forbids uh uh
ideological and political teaching in
schools but so we'll we'll get there
eventually I think and we'll get back to
the idea of um liberal values and and
and and gay rights and women's rights
and and free speech and all of these
things that we had sort of agreed on at
one point I'm really optimistic I think
too many crazy things have happened I
think it's images like Leah Thomas on
the podium towering over those women I
think every time something like that
happens people think what this is
actually happening did you know that
male rapists were being housed in female
prisons probably not but they are I
missed a bit when being cool with gay
people was cool like you could say that
and feel really liberal you know and and
brief window yeah well my son's uh you
know his God Parents two married gay men
I used to love throwing that in the face
of people that would think like you get
cedos for that you I remember back in
the Ed Fringe years ago I used to say
that and the room went silent I was like
yeah I out liberal juice but now it's
that's being fine with gays is very last
year gays are the problem now that's the
thing your
nonb don't don't get rid of gays love
gays Jeff you as as optimistic as Andrew
about the you know the there are a lot
of debates actually where the pendulum
goes one way and you think it's l and
then it and then it comes back the other
way I think that ultimately the debate
that has the most chance of resonating
with reasonable members of the public
will be the one that triumphs in the
long run yeah the the interesting thing
to me is I'm temperamentally very
tempted to agree with Andrew but then I
have how long you been doing the show
six years and you've been spending a lot
of time with me in that and I've been
spending a lot of time with the
depressive so I look at the last six
years I sort of think we probably would
have said that at every point every year
around Christmas in every point in the
last six years and so far it just gets
worse we have seen a lot of you know
actual progress I mean Hannah Barnes
who's a newsight editor she had she had
a brilliant book about this and uh it
really got resonance I think you're
seeing Stonewall and mermaids being
pulled out of the institutions where
they were giving advice all of these
things are to be welcomed but um broadly
I I I'm torn honestly but because we now
can have the debate because the era of
no debate is over uh once you have this
debate it's fairly clear which side the
public are going to fall on the reason
why Stonewall always said no debate is
because this stuff doesn't withstand
that kind of scrutiny what do you think
mate I actually I'm in agreement with
Andrew I think that what five years do
you think give it five years and it'll
be gone well I think this is the start
because you've got to hit hit a moment
where like I said that the shark moment
and for me it was Isa Bryson with a face
tattoo two time male rapists in a
woman's prison where people like what
and I think more and more and I think
the thing that we're not talking about
but that's actually really going to play
a part in all of this collapsing is the
fact that mainstream media they're
hemorrhaging viewers they're
hemorrhaging influence if you look at
Channel 4 which does all this kind of
stuff on the last leg the last leg I was
talking to a producer I think it was a
Channel 4 comedy producer who was
basically saying to me but we're
hemorrhaging viewers no one's watching
the stuff anymore yeah they're putting
out all of this content it's crap it's
just lecturing people and nobody's
watching it and I think the more and
more that happens the less powerful and
less prevalent this is going to be is
this really true Jeff because you're
someone who does all the big shows
comedy shows on TV I I did most of them
once but you know you're very much in
that kind of environment I'm a double-
agent let's call it you play Both Sides
both you're bisexual you're nonbinary
you're
nonbinary is it because I think there's
a danger of people like us particularly
the two of us and also to some extent
Andrew where you know we spend a lot of
time in this kind of online space it's
very tempting for us to tell ourselves
the story oh look at the mainstream
media they're crumbling their ratings
look at they canel mock the week oh look
they cancel this the mass reports no
longer there that you you used to be on
I used to work with you on Etc is it
true
I think that um if like the last leg
still does well in relative terms you
know um so if it's still on it's
probably because it's doing well
particularly on a on a commercial
channel so I think that there's a
problem I mean such a big problem for
terrestrial television generally if you
look at the drop in ratings that I don't
know what last legs ratings are but
whatever it might have dropped it'll
probably be in line with most of it so
they you know the problem for comedy
generally if that's kind of where this
discussion is going is that is just at
the time right maybe about 2016 2017
where streamers started to have
influence where um YouTube like people
could basically go and get the comedy
that they want whether it's edgy comedy
on liners introspective they could
basically go and get it just at that
point on terrestrial television it
became afraid of its own shadow a little
bit you know and it became risk averse
and it had all sorts of things that it
had to attend to which got in the way of
Simply going is this funny is this going
to appeal to a broad audience so it's
been kind of you know it's been kind of
kind of hampered uh in a in a big way
you know because like if you go comedy
so visceral right you watch something
you go that guy's funny or that one's
funny I'm going to go and see him on
talk it it occurs within you it's a
physical thing so you can't put in a
laugh track or or do any of that and and
if you're not satisfied right because
it's so visceral you'll go where else
can I get that feeling because laughing
is a great feeling that's exactly what
they negated wasn't it but the activist
did to Comedy and so far as they were
expecting audiences to sit there hear
the joke assess whether it was morally
pure
and then laugh to endorse the point
being made and that's not how laughter
works I mean I think that there is now
uh it's going back a bit you know like
when I have meetings and stuff and I
speak to people you know if for example
Channel 4 last year they backed Jimmy
car after that joke from his Netflix
special yeah you know we see Netflix
standing their ground the meetings that
I'm having with people at the BBC
they're like we want it to have tth and
we want it it just it feels like there
was some Lost Years in there somewhere I
mean I would say that one place is
genuinely you know that that talk to Jim
um just Jim Davis [__] sake this will
this will this will go down well Tim
Davis um when he said about having
diversity of opinion which is not a
controversial view to to anybody I think
the the BBC Radio actually really was
the only ones that really consistently
ran with that you know if you look at
like things like particularly news quiz
where just have you know every s have
someone like me someone like Simon Evans
someone like you you know Alan Cochran
will pop up on there they cuz I think it
just makes it better the point is it's
nothing it's nothing ideological yeah I
did the moral maze this year as well I
mean they are trying something's
changing because I've noticed this with
like you know when I set up comedy
unleash like five years ago with Andy
Shaw and and lots of people said oh
there's no need for any of this which we
don't get that criticism anymore because
because comedians do get canceled um but
we've had recently a guardian article
about it that wasn't a hit piece I mean
it was it was you know it was a bit
sniffy and sneery but it wasn't a hit
piece we had a nice thing in sky sky
covered it they came along to F I
thought were going to do a hit piece and
it was just actually quite nice I think
that there's really good like green
shoots um of a kind of recovery recovery
is just to remembering that comedy is
comedy and it's supposed to be funny but
the contro controversy around Matt R
right if people so you know guy got hug
what is the controversy so the
controversy was was there was a joke at
the beginning of his special which
essentially was it was a domestic uh
violence joke in many ways personally I
didn't like the joke but I recognized
that it was just a joke I was surprised
that it was in his special I just didn't
think it met the quality threshold for
something like that But ultimately that
that was his choice the audience on the
night is first to say laughed at it
quite heartedly what I thought was
really heartening on Tik Tok and other
places was the young people coming from
him no one was saying he should lose his
job no one was saying his thing should
be taken down what they were doing was
they were attacking the joke they were
attacking the idea and I think good that
is that's all that's happened is that
it's gone back to how it should have
always been it's not quite there yeah
but but even within a year I mean if you
take like when Jerry sadt Show got
cancelled by Pleasants last year last
Edinburgh Fringe and he's like as you
know major veteran of the circuit and
respected by all the sort of woke Comics
as well uh but this year when when our
show got cancelled by uh the leth arches
in Edinburgh because graem linam was on
the bill uh and then it got canceled by
a second venue and the show ended up on
a platform outside in the open air
outside the Scottish Parliament but lots
of people said this was ridiculous even
some people I didn't expect you know the
people the comedians who normally say
yeah well you shouldn't say problem
things then started coming out and say
actually so I mean just don't go and see
a comedy show if if you think you'll be
offended don't cancel it that's a big
shift even within that year I think the
responses to those two shows shows that
it's it's changing well do you know what
happens though is over time everyone
would have been told off the longer this
thing goes so the I most I think in many
ways leftwing Comics uh you know
Progressive Comics get more crap than we
do because the people look at us and go
well these guys they'll say out of all
the stuff that's what they do they
ourselves you know and stuff but the
thing is with when you're on the left
sometimes you're you're hemmed in where
you're there's these expectations if you
step out of line you'll get absolutely
devoured so over time what happens is
Comics goes well I thought I was on that
side and you all tried to destroy me and
so they realize they're worse with each
other AR they can be and what what they
realize over time is like like actually
it's really precious to just be able to
to to have the right to get it wrong no
I don't mind people say I didn't like
that joke because it's when I didn't
like that joke and you should use lose
your living
those I mean it really is a terrible
thing to not have a sense of humor or or
to to be I think of all the things you
could be upset about at the moment
comedy is just is just the weirdest one
and on that very Point unless you wanted
to yeah I was just going to just add as
well it's uh it's I should have
mentioned my tour at that point I mean
it was
absolutely I me Conant was literally
looking at me like okay we got it onto
the comedy subject somehow and my
incredibly controversial show are people
being remember you're the W one on here
yeah exactly my Edge Lord but basic
bloke people have been passing out it's
like you know those hor those horror
films in the 70s it's just it's um yeah
that's on tour um next year but I say
this is like one thing that never
changed and I'm sure you guys would have
experienced this live audiences were
always great you know more or less
always there was a tiny percentage of
people that got emboldened but it was
never like how it was on social media
cuz you know most people right that's
right that is very true I did get booed
at gig on Thursday but well let's leave
that other that's just Quality quality
what had you said can you give us a
flavor of what it was you'd upset how
you'd upset them um well it was it was a
new material night and and they were
very very Progressive was it your new
material night no no no no
they
psychopath yeah they heckled you off the
stage yeah and you you deserved it and I
I gave him a little round of applause
when you left no it was I remember you
were looking at going what is going on
here and that was a truly beautiful
moment for me Jeff well you made me
realize that my audience like just
seemed like like rabid centus compared
to whatever Rabel you've procured yeah
the absolute lunatics yeah no I I just I
just did a joke about pronouns and um
and you got booed by your audence yeah
yeah well no no no no this was a new
material night which is very nice gig a
new material gig and then they were they
were already upset and then I went look
I'm going to bring it down let's not
let's not get upset I'm just going to do
some bits about Israel Palestine and
that really like even though it wasn't
controversial the bit they heard the
words and I did it and it just went
further and further and you know it's
bad because the only laughter I could
hear was the laughter of the comedians
well that that's when you know it's
really gone down that's still quite
enjoyable isn't it yeah yeah it was what
was the pronouns joke uh what was the
pronouns joke I'm still working on it so
yeah no it was just a [__] joke yeah cuz
if it was a grown that's a slightly
different thing no it was a hiss it was
a wow wow pan seon
we'll get back to the episode in a
minute but first we want to tell you
about our sponsor Verso in our recent
interview with Tim Urban he said we
should be talking about longevity and
Longevity science researchers like the
biologist David Sinclair have recently
made some fascinating discoveries on how
to mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products I take every
day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repair
damaged DNA and increase energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
the video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join us you can get
15% off by going to
the.so that's
v.s o and use code trigger to save 15%
off your order now back to the interview
anyway smoothly moving on very smoothly
you Jeff you were saying I can't believe
people would get upset about comedy in
the current moment and of course next
year we have two elections one here one
in the United States uh Donald Trump
might be running from prison unlikely
Could Happen uh you know what's going to
happen in the UK as well like we're
looking forward to that what are you
guys thinking about I think America is
insane the idea how gangster would that
be if he ran from prison like he does it
over Zoom right he's like that would be
that would be astonishing and I didn't
realize you could do that but apparently
in America that that you can you can
even if you've been a a prosecutor you
can you can still run but I I just think
it's it's it's is is that the best they
can do and Biden I mean I don't think
the Democrats Ever Wanted Biden around
and I don't think he wants to be there
and the whole thing is so tragic I I
don't know the poity of of options is
going to be an issue in both both
elections you know and that could effect
turnout which you'd say might sort of
benefit the more conservative so that
tend to be more mobilized for voting but
you look when when Trump won against
Hillary a lot of leftwing people lost
their minds how could you do this this
guy is a top toxic figure I don't know
if it'll be the same next time because I
think even those people might go well
the other guy is Ceno like it really and
and is an incredible situation where
Trump gets to seem like the sprightly
Young Thing against Jo I mean you got
these you got two guys essentially that
could cause a World War one because he
was upset and the other one by accident
you know Joe Biden I mean it's such a
serious thing you know in the states
being commander-in-chief having the
nuclear codes all those things and you
know you cannot judge an American voter
who at that point says I don't want
somebody who's clearly suffering with
mental issues to be that person and on
that very point I think one of the
things that really plays into Trump's
hands and he's clearly going to be the
nominee as we sit here today and and
he's ahead of Biden as far as I
understand in terms of the polling is
that what you have seen since Biden has
come in and this may be maybe
correlations not cation but it might be
you know the the the collapse of
American power around the world the fact
that uh people are quite happy you know
Putin is quite happy to have a little
nibble at Ukraine you know under Biden's
watch look at what happened in
Afghanistan Israel Palestine I mean that
is clearly you know it's America's
Central Ally in the Middle East Iran
feeling free to to to support Hamas into
making that attack it just shows you
that the the the fear and respect that
America commands around the world is
declining and when you've got a guy who
keeps falling over and you know he
clearly not at his Peak in charge it's
not unreasonable for for the American
public to think well whatever that guy
might be tweeting and you know January
the 6th was not a good look and not a
good to thing thing to have happened and
lots of other issues that people will
have with Trump you just look at that
and you go on balance do I want this or
do I go want the guy with the Mean
Tweets and I think a lot of people will
will see that as a quite an Easy Choice
iect well I I think the thing with Trump
that you notice that some of the foreign
policy the issues overseas didn't happen
because I guess it's partly because of
he's a deeply flawed character Donald
Trump but part of that is was Putin was
unsure of how he might react right do
you remember when he he bombed that air
strip in Syria no one expected that to
happen that clearly uh surprised the
Russian Administration it doesn't seem
to me what when did when did Trump leave
office uh it was 2020 right so the
inauguration early 2021 2021 right
because they had their election yeah
invasion of Ukraine happens you know
yeah so you saying no no that happened
in 2022 sorry but a year after was
Afghanistan first Afghanistan pull out
was first which was a disaster then you
get Ukraine and now you get Israel I'm
not saying for one second if Donald
Trump's in in in position and none of
those things happen but the the
unpredictability of him if you're War
gaming a reaction I feel with certain
certainty they could say well there's a
line that Biden won't cross I wonder if
that's the same but the downside of that
is that he might cross that line I mean
so you could say you know having someone
unhinged in charge is great because
people are nervous and he's my psych but
I'm I'm so surprised a republican I know
I think you're probably right it is
wrapped up for Trump but you know if
they had gone with someone like Dan
Santas then Biden would have been
creamed absolutely like I think Biden's
creamed anyway mate I'm not so sure
because the resentment against Trump is
so extreme that the ones who would
typically vote Republican there's a lot
of them out there who won't who won't do
it do you think that there are younger
voters that were so hellbent on getting
Trump out that time that was it was
almost like get brexit done in a way
it's one of those single isue things
that actually people people mistake it
as a mass endorsement of a party or a
politician when actually it's it's one
thing get Trump out now that having
happened and Biden having frankly
disappointed a lot of people on the left
left in the states I wonder if they see
if they're as mobilized or motivated to
do that again that is a good point and
by the way Biden has been very strong on
on supporting
Israel and has alienated a lot of his
voters as a result yeah the people that
you know the Democratic party has been
courting for some time so Biden it's not
like Biden has done everything badly but
you have to look at it on balance and
and for the Americans especially you
know Francis and I fortunate enough to
spend a little bit more time there
nowadays when you talk to people there I
you know I think um seeing their country
become weaker on the international stage
is something that really affects people
and how they see how they see their
presid how they see the political system
uh and also if you look at the economy
you know things are getting so expensive
yeah and that may have happened under
trump it may not but you know the
economy is something that people will
judge a politician on even if it's not
their responsibility and it hasn't been
a good time for America I mean I'm I'm
now thinking maybe I've being a bit
unfair on Biden with foreign policy
because there initially with Ukraine was
a very strong sort of reaction that's
ebed away I guess there's a chance with
Trump that he'd have just got not my
business not committing our money there
not Comm in our troops you know it's but
that's the point in a way with Trump is
it's just not clearcut what he'll do is
an advantage I mean in geopolitics that
is an advantage if people don't know
what your move is going to be it means
they have to be extra careful as a
result and you are then not in a war
where Ukraine has been invaded because
that has already been prevented do you
see what I mean that is the argument the
prot Trump people will make so we'll
find out what happens there but
interesting for us obviously all four of
us being based here in the UK is how
that maps on to the ction here because
my sense is labor are going to win uh
quite possibly a landslide win without
actually that being an endorsement to
your point of the labor party it might
just be a a plague on both your houses
but there's more plague for the Tories
and for labor and as a result labor ends
up with with a majority well I mean you
know the 2019 general election Victory
so much of that was put down to Boris
the fer personality he's done it but he
also was up against you know get brexit
done which was a great campaign idea
Labor's position that time and I love to
mention it as often as I can was they
were going to crack a new deal and then
put it to a referendum when they
campaigned against it which was a
complete non-pos on the single biggest
thing facing the country at the time
Corbin was massively unpopular so again
some of what happens in the elections is
things get mistaken as a single thing
that drove it or a single personality
and and yeah like if labor get in it
will be interesting to see what starma I
going say if it's almost overwhelmingly
unlik whelmingly likely is a what starm
interprets that as I think like in a
weird way for him a big majority could
be tricky because there'll be loads of
Labor people that go right we've got a
200 seat majority let's do some really
leftwing stuff he's like that's not what
I was voted in for they go all right two
years in you're out son uh we'll get in
Andy Burnham and because they'll feel
like they've got time to pull it back
before the next election so I wonder if
just like when Cameron there was that
Coalition in 2010 that kept people in
line whether for starmer's point of view
a 60 seat majority might be more
manageable than a 200 seat one well
maybe maybe it won't be that maybe there
won't be a landslide I mean I I have a
kind of feeling that what could happen
here is that it won't be a landslide
there'll be a coalition I think and and
you might even end up with a situation
where he has to go for electoral reform
as part of the bargain and if that
happen and I and I hope that happens do
I think we need something needs to
change fundamentally and I think PR is
the way to go I think proportional
representation is the way to go I think
if that happens then the whole field is
open now it means smaller parties can
make some kind of a difference it means
that we can get uh we can have a more
Democratic Society and it works
perfectly well in European countries
these coalitions I I I don't have any Fe
well you know one of the funniest things
in the last couple of years were when it
was still quite tight between labor and
the Tories there was all that stuff hash
Progressive Alliance Progressive
Alliance the lib Dem bless and they got
so excited and and then the moment that
La opened up a significant poll lead the
lip Dems just got ghosted out of
existence and that that hashtag stopped
appearing it is a weird thing with the
lib Dems right they should be a force
right now because you've got a deeply
unpopular party in power you've got a
labor party that are apathetic and
disappointing their base already before
they've even got in power at least Blair
weighted until he was in four years
right lib them they just don't have an
identity nationally and when they
campaign they tend to like they'll say
one thing in one constituency they'll
say we we we want to build loads of
houses and they'll say well we don't
want that and they'll go well nor do we
we're against that and then and they'll
go to another byelection and they'll say
the opposite because because they're
able to do that in byelections I think
the moment they have to have a national
platform yeah they're going to struggle
I mean this is weird people say why why
has this ended up being a beat up on the
lib Dems I guess the point is is that
this should be ripe for a third party to
make a difference and actually the third
party that's more likely to make a
difference now is reform exactly and the
interesting thing about reform is is not
actually reform it's the person who set
up reform which is Nigel farage who you
think is going to be the leader of the
Tory party well I don't think I don't
know if he's going to be the leader of
the Tory party but I think what Nigel is
a political Joker in the past back and
the move that Nigel makes will
significantly influence the result of
the next general election I think if he
puts if he goes full on reform and it's
like look we're going to hold the
conservatives feet to the fire we can
all agree the conservative party is no
longer fit for purpose you may vote for
them and they may say a few things but
it's not going to happen we all know it
vote for change that will have a very
real impact not only on the
conservatives but also on labor because
there's this attitude amongst labor that
oh you know workingclass people have
been disappointed the Tories they're
going to come back to us well why should
they when you have failed them for
Generations when soel had to leave the
government actually what you saw is a
lot of people saying well workingclass
people in the north I mean that
basically lost the Tory party the red W
per leaving and those people then are
going to vote for labor a lot of them
are going to vote for reform or abstain
completely and labor may end up getting
back in but that isn't you see what I'm
say the thing about reform though is
they don't stand a big just like you k
chance of winning in any single
constituency so they they can pile 11 or
12% whereas the libdems actually got
chances of of winning seats if we had if
we had P PR you know they would be I
agree with you Jeff what they can do is
take maybe enough votes away from the
conservatives that somebody else comes
in like a li like a lib Dem for example
or maybe they could mobilize enough of
the you know traditional workingclass
old school labor that it might mean that
another party gets in or a conservative
might win so it's going to be very
interesting to see the moves that Nigel
makes because I think that is going to
have a very real significant impact on
the result of the election I mean I it
was interesting with far on I'm a
celebrity um I don't know if you saw him
did you see him in the shorts no he's I
mean this is very fous but he was
packing heat down there he really was
definitely I mean have you not seen this
I mean this what do you mean by that
remark pack stacked downstairs he's Oh I
thought you meant he was armed no no no
no
imagine if he G in the jungle with a sh
and he's just like right well well
Bell's quite Dar and you know I need to
handle myself yeah I basically say he's
got a big [__] which is probably like
the most the most Low brown thing I
could have I I could have said he also
dressed to the right which a lot of
people noce but the I think that the I
think what's interesting about him on
that was that I don't actually think he
mobilized people to vote for him very
well but all all he did was a sort of
politician's job on that I think he has
like he has a strong appeal because he
communicates in this direct way but I
don't know if he's going to I the
problem with him going to the Tories
right is they're already in a battle in
the blue wall now with lib Dems if he
goes to the Tories then there's a lot of
people just go well I'll vote lib Dem
because that guy is distasteful to me so
they're in this weird electoral thing
that labor almost had in 2019 so I don't
think it's as simple as frage goes to
the Tories and that sorts them out that
just present pres with but the
difficulty with n Nigel farage going to
the Tories is the Tor part
is actually against him the Tor party is
way to the left of the Tor voting base
so that's why I don't think yeah so I I
don't think that will happen uh but what
what I think will happen is whether
reform is see I don't think most people
could name you a single policy that
reform has it's a protest vote it's not
criticism it's a sentiment isn't it like
things are out of control the country's
going if there if there SL was the
country is going to the dogs absolutely
bloody absolutely but one thing I'm not
so sure about Andrew is this idea that
the the the pi is the answer to all our
problems I don't look at Europe and
think oh that's how we should do it I
mean one of the things you know we we've
talked about this I think with David
starky when he we were talking about
proportion representation is the the the
first pass supp post system we have here
that produces two major parties is very
good at defanging the extremes of each
party it prevents the emergence of
extremist parties I think if you went to
PR now you going to get some pretty
extreme things on both sides well I
suppose I should clarify I don't think
PR is the the solution to all our
problems I don't think that but I but I
am a Democrat and I do believe in
democracy and I do like I I think it was
completely outrageous that when ukip won
that massive share of the vote and they
ended up with what one seat or something
I mean just they already had which is
something really ridiculous it's like
that's just not Democratic so I think on
a point of principle we should have PR
whether whether it even if it [__]
everything up eventually I still think
we should have P I like with brexit i i
you're still on the left M principle
about what above reality yeah a lot of
people say well brexit would cause
economic ruination okay fine we should
still do it because the principle is
right you should be able to vote out the
people in charge and we can't do it when
we're with the EU I speaking of the EU I
heard an interesting theory is like
we've had a lot of European countries
partly because of PR moved to the right
quite significantly in some cases is I
think it was in the new Statesman
there's an article saying that in 10
years time you could find that a lot as
the EU moves in line with those sort of
political movements a lot of remainers
go maybe you know not necessarily or we
don't want to be in it but well perhaps
it's not the kind of uh band of kindly
Wizards that we once thought it was and
then loads of brexiteers going oh the
temperature looks nice in there it could
be time jooin because actually
ultimately we've got the European
elections coming up um is that if
there's far right or or significantly
right-wing country uh admin ations in a
lot of these countries policy would
eventually have to reflect that no
that's good though isn't it that's what
I mean that's what's good about PR is
that if if the risk is that a far right
party can come to power at least have a
major clout because the the Centrist
parties just aren't addressing those
issues then that's a good argument for
that isn't it because that's a that
means I I'm just saying that could we
could see an interesting flip on
remainer and rejoin center it's not that
they don't they don't like it's not they
don't like the idea of the European
project but the temperature of that
swimming pool is like oh that's a bit
you know that's not my that's not my
scene as much and also I think you know
when it comes to rejoining the EU there
was a graph that I saw today that shows
like basically the surge in in belief
that we were wrong to leave the EU
literally goes in line with the cost of
living crisis of course now now I'm not
going to say that that once the economy
improves everyone will be Pro brexit but
I do think that the the the sort of
dissatisfaction with it has been
exacerbated by the fact everyone feels
[__] skinned I don't think the regoin
things ever going Happ the thing is
there are many many countries in Europe
that are worse off and as you know both
of us voted remain but there was a you
know there's this Larry something I can
never remember name from the larot the
lone straight white man who still rides
for the guardian he wrote what's going
on with the guardian they they are they
based now no no they just have one they
keep them they have one for diversity um
they gave him a good review yeah weird
he wrote an article uh no this isn't the
one he wrote an article basically saying
uh the rejoin thing's never going to
happen because people actually do
realize that yeah things are not great
in the UK they're much worse in many
European countries we've recovered
better than Germany better than France
you know it's not it's it's the argum
we're talking look I don't know about a
great deal about you know European
politics and but there are some let's
just say very right-wing parties that
are doing very well in a lot of European
countries yeah so this idea that you
know you're going to move to we're going
to go back into the EU and everybody in
the EU is having this wonderful time it
there's a lot of very angry very
frustrated people who have got a lot of
legitimate criticisms with the EU if you
look at basically the vast majority of
Southern European countries they want
out of the EU a lot of them do I just
hope Holland doesn't ban weed um on that
happy note should we do a couple of
frivolous stories before we head on over
to uh our pay wall section where we talk
about our predictions for the future and
all that uh we had uh the somerset [__]
we had French Priests get Amber a lot
for noning we got to I mean I never
thought i' say could we do the French
priest nons instead theen I want to know
about the somerset game we will do we
will do Jeff is worried for his career
exactly [__] in the think it's a very
dark news story it sounds funny but this
is a story about French Catholic priests
will be forced to wear scannable QR code
so the public can identify if they're a
sex offender does that imply that the
majority are well that's sort of where
the funny angle in this comes in because
actually this is a story about uh
priests abusing children so it's not
that frivolous however if you think
about the fact that this indicates that
most of them probably are nonsense then
it becomes really funny I think it's a
bit like you know you know when you got
got a cat that kills loads of sparrows
you have to put a bell on its NE that
but for nons my my my favorite about all
of this is red I get green I get that's
all clear he good you're good to go what
about orange orange it's it's where
you're sort of not sure but you're
willing to take the risk anyway is it a
color code yeah Catholic priests in
France will be made to traffic light
coded identification tags to allow the
public to check whether they may have
faced sexual abuse charges cards will
feature a QR code scanable by mobile
phone that will flag a red orange or
green light depending on whether its
holder had been stripped of clerical
status the scheme announced by The
Bishop's Conference of France on
Wednesday will allow easier
identification of priests able to lead
mass and hear confessions this cannot be
real isn't this also a decorum issue you
can't just go around scanning priests
well unless you really have to but look
at their history no but you like but how
would this work in practice you see a
priest you go up to with your phone just
do they just acques to this is there any
kind of discourse that takes place could
I scan you father does does the father
get to consent I mean there's all sorts
of it's a mind field I just I honestly I
was at some point I thought you were
going to say like oh it was mentioned at
a town meeting you know some of these
stories that got are sort of like fairly
Basel just getting decided at the
highest level this is like the Premier
League of nons but no the Vatican didn't
sign up on this did they there's no way
the Vatican no they don't want scanning
for nonsense exactly how are they going
to replace her entire Workforce so who
put this in was this the government was
this macron no those the French
Church no so here we go members of the
public will see either a red light an
amber light or a green light upon
scanning one of the new cards red lights
indicate that a priest has been stripped
of their status and cannot perform
various clerical duties the database
will up will be updated a stand a
standard once a year or immediately in
cases of serious misconduct orange
lights will indicate that a priest has
limited powers due to experience or
sanction that's a semn yeah like so
that's someone who's done a bit yeah
yeah so someone's just dabbled in
nonsense yeah well we don't know yeah
Shing does nons okay you know like when
I watch Christmas specials growing up
Mor and wise VRE they didn't talk about
non priest I'm telling you that much
when are we doing the song dance routine
I'll be up for that you know I just
think like what do you do with those
orange ones no exactly you can't this is
I don't think you should have any kind
of system where you have to like wear
something to show that you're not
something terrible it's like you
remember when they tried to introduce
the safety pin that you'd put a safety
pin on if you weren't a racist yeah and
there was a campaign to do this when
when during BLM that happened I actually
know the woman who started it I used to
be friends when when did this happen it
was a while ago when was it Con about I
noticed you weren't wearing a pin Mas
where's your PIN mate why do you hate
them silence is
violence the default expectation of a
priest should be that he won't uh commit
sexual not based on fact he or she he or
she also let's look at the facts because
we got to be objective I don't think if
you look at the history and the facts
that is the basic assumption we should
make about but Sur if a priest has a red
thing right they wouldn't be a priest
anymore anyway they would be they would
have been ditched it says that so why
would they why would you need to scam
them it's a good point do you know the
things that like when you do something
like this you you sort of war game what
could you get in trouble for there are
so many subjects where you could have I
reckon it'll be this I reckon it'll be
comedians not just joke about but
endorse noning they'll get a little bit
of what we say what you mean we're
anti-n yeah well I mean well you're the
woke so you have to go the other way oh
Jeff you're woke you've got to be prone
they're called Maps Min attracted people
pedophiles yeah is that is that a thing
minor Attractive people and there are
some activists who want that to be part
of LGBT
this it's sexual orientation according
to them they can't help it this is a
prank you cannot tell me that main this
minor attractive persons map yeah Jeff
who's saying this Jeff relax all these
TV shows that you do they're dying
anyway welcome come in the water's
lovely what who's saying that that's a
thing your podcast is crushing it look
forget about mainstream who is saying
that minor attracted person should be
the word instead of nons the map map
activ map activist and and these are
there are some of there always have been
it's like I feel like
1970 down har Harman labor MP used to be
a member of something called the
pedophile information exchange she
wasn't a member I think she she endorsed
or
supported something yeah something I
take that back she didn't used to be a
member of war was Andre I I think she
appeared at something that they did or
or at least wrote in support or said
something was she was Peter information
exchanger Jason that's that's this was
before the now we're just playing like
cancel mind
[Laughter]
sweeper you know what Jeff's
uncomfortable face is the best thing
about is this been the highlight I don't
I don't mind cancel stuff the the the
litigious stuff that's the you haven't
said anything you haven't said it's us
going down silence is violence yeah
exactly my favorite thing during that
whole episode was uh there was a girl in
the t- show that said silence is consent
yeah and I was like have you applied
this to other contexts yeah that
wouldn't work would it
cuz it was it was about racism she was
saying if you're you're silent
complicity me complicity but it said
consent and you're going you map this
onto other that Cas yeah that's the
problem with slogans they sound great
when you say them you're like yes and
then you think you look down a bit there
is a tendency on the left that they do
like the progressive left I should say
where they like um an incantation oh
they love it no one's safe till
everyone's safe like well that's not
like it's just my logic brain you go
well that's not exactly true you know
someone's Liberation is everyone's and
you go it maybe it just feels good to
say these little sing song things often
these slogans though what is it Robert J
lifton called them thought terminating
clichs because you say them in
substitute of an argument because
because the arguments don't stand up so
instead just have a slogan and and you
have to you have to agree with the
slogan I think that's the pur we were a
pro Palestine protest by by accident
where we were just walking past and it
was interesting to me while while Hamas
holds hundreds of Jewish host Israeli
hostages they were chanting no justice
no peace yeah and I thought have you
thought I mean no they haven't thought
any of it have they but then you said
there were quers for Palestine there at
that they were that one they were they
were actually quer for Palestine I went
to another protest a pro Palestine one
which was a smaller one which was you
know I there's a there's a video on our
Channel that's I think it's approaching
like half a million views now where it
was a kind of interesting range of
of opinions and it wasn't like that
silly but the one we saw was like
completely incoherent and the arguments
completely incoherent anyway we're
getting serious again shall we do
another frivolous story yeah well I
think we should do the [__] thing just
because I don't know about this je is
going to sink into I didn't know that
Somerset had gimps I it's very
Progressive no you talk about the BBC
with a misleading headline I don't think
it's wriggling is the problem I think
it's dry humping stuff do best tell
well read the headline if you stick the
headline back up Somerset Gardener
banned from wriggling in [__] suits
excellent that's more of a pirate accent
yeah there is more pirate yeah so why do
you think this is a very dark story well
because this guy you know at first it
was like there was sigh into the [__]
and that one's sort of funny yeah the
word [__] is funny but it sort of turned
out that by and large he was just like
making women feel uncomfortable what do
you think gimp's do he nor yeah it's
normally [__] in my mind is a consensual
type businessman saying can I be your
gift look at that tell me that picture
is not funny what was he was he actually
assaulting people no he was just making
the yeah but then but then there was a
lot of weird bre look I'll put it this
way if my wife come home and said that
that guy had followed her I'd [__]
batter
him against the law exactly and what
you're doing there is quite literally
punching down on I will happily Advocate
violence to follow women in [__] outfits
is it legal to walk around in a [__]
suit because well that's what I'm asking
why don't we read the [__] article
that's good point a gardener who
terrified women in Somerset in a
Somerset Village rather has been banned
from writhing on the floor in an old
black body suit in public so I'm
guessing it isn't illegal but he's been
banned okay immediately wriggling to
writhing
esal rling I think is fine writhing is
what is this Legend's name Joshua hunt
32 was found guilty last week of causing
intentional harassment alarm or distress
to his victims he has now been handed a
sexual harm risk order which prevents
him from wearing any type of mask unless
for medical reasons the order will be in
place for 5 years so he's not allowed to
wear any kind of mask yeah I mean that
does seem B going to make Carnival so so
boring it doesn't sound to me like he'
done anything illegal there I think
what's weird there is because they
obiously don't understand the Mas thing
they just got just any any kind of mask
here they don't un they don't understand
it I guess I mean what first off you
just roll it back down the mask I mean I
that doesn't really fit with what I
that's more Halloweeny I would say it's
it's a little bit Beast of Jersey isn't
it it's that sort of like scary
fetishy thing I mean but is that illegal
I mean if you're going to criminalize
that kind of thing do you remember when
there was that Spate of people who
dressed up as clowns and chased people
with chainsaws yeah that that that to me
should is comparable I think there
should be something in that but actual
chainsaws I think they did just as a
kind of with the chain removed or
something but it was like it didn't know
yeah the restrictions on this guy get
better among the restrictions imposed
Hunt is now banned from being in
possession of any type of mask or face
covering in a public place so no Pro
Palestine protest for him wearing or
being in possession of black all-in-one
garment in a public place so you can't
wear a burer either uh crawling
wriggling or writhing on the floor in a
public place whilst wearing a full body
covering clothing that appears like a
full body covering and or Mask full face
Andor full face I think sounds quite
authoritarian to me because now you're
policing his dress sense but you know
that there is that modern thing like
Kink shaming right they say you should
never shame anybody's Kings yeah you
should you should there's some stuff
that is utterly depraved of I'm happy to
go like a 1950s conservative on this he
needs bloody help he's wrong in the head
if if that's how he gets his kicks I
think he should be on a [__] watch
this is the exact opposite of what the
BBC have promoted did you see this
episode of doctors about furries where a
guy basically who gets a kick out of
dressing as a bear is thrown out of his
house by his his prejudiced old
grandfather and then he goes to a
nightclub and takes the grandfather
along and someone's sitting there
dressed as a cow and there's a pig and
there's all sort and the grandfather
realizes he just needs to be accepting
he wouldn't be the first bear in my club
boom boom I was going to
say that I have like with people like a
Christmas special exactly with people
like fures there's a kind of sympathy
that I have for them because there's a
moment when you're young where you're
discovering your sexuality where you
finding out what it is that you like and
what you don't like can you imagine
realizing that you really like it when
your partner gets gets into a cow suit
and you're in a bear outfit you know
that but it's aort thing you keep to
yourself isn't it you should be ashamed
of it yeah I go straight to the
therapist I go all something's gone
wrong here why do I why do I like this
there's a big furry community now you
know that it's it's it's kind of it's
the next civil rights issue I'm
definitely going to leave this with more
questions and answers the education of
Jeff nor progress here do you know Jeff
this has been beautiful mate it's just
watching a mind slow my man slowly have
his mind blown I want to sit in my
little middle England bubble you know
getting a bit cross about something I'm
diet gamon I like to think of myself as
a diet gam not the full the low sodium
gam yeah well too late well on that
happy note gentlemen we're going to head
over to our supporters where we're going
to talk about our predictions for 2024
and catch up on a bunch of other stuff
so that is going to be extra special
content and we're going to be wearing
weird hats as well we've got all sorts
of Christmas app before we go let's get
them out for the lads uh IIA what we
wearing get them out for the lads there
we go there we go can I have the antlers
I quite F Jeff bagged the antlers no
he's got the yeah but that goes on there
doesn't it oh does it oh no you got I
mean this isn't especially festive on
its own say here we go it's just a I'm
not wearing is this a wig or a beard I
think is it a be beard you you should go
the beard because it'll go it will go
your trim
bab G me a just oil t-shirt which I'm
not going to wear I mean this is got to
be the weirdest recorder we've gone
right from the most serious issues and
I've ended wearing a [__] deer
stalker all right head on over to locals
and check out the bonus content there
Sant Santa's always been fetishy how did
you mean well because the he he comes
down your chimney at night oh no I
didn't mean that in a sexual way yeah I
mean that's a that's a
fantasy